The joe rogan experience.
We were talking a little bit earlier,
how much of your life
revolves around on it?
Yeah.
There you go.
How much year of life revolves
around the pleasure that food,
booze,
you know,
before the podcast started about making
the choice between booze and food.
Like if you could eat whatever the fuck
you want it to be healthy and live til
you're fucking 90 and all that shit or,
but you couldn't drink or you could drink,
but he can't eat shit,
you gotta eat cardboard and
the fucking grape leaves.
Oh,
okay,
well,
I'm going to work great.
Please give cardboard and fucking grass.
I truly believe that living without
good food and living without,
uh,
I mean,
if you're going to survive,
you're,
you know,
if you live in,
in the walking dead and you
got to shoot deer and shit,
that's all well and good,
but we're talking about
in this day and age,
I'm talking to you.
You have a choice.
If you have to make a choice between I
can eat my favorite shit or I can drink
booze and,
and,
and have the added sort
of crank that that give.
Well,
what I was going to say was that the,
the idea of,
you know,
subsistence living is all although
frightening that food is delicious.
Eating deer over a campfire.
That's a really yummy tasting food,
right?
If you're saying like shitty food,
like cardboard tasting bland food,
that's a sergeant.
The enjoyment of the day in my opinion,
my meal with my family I think is uh,
I one of my favorite things in life and
that sounds like it sounds uttered like
utter horse shit,
the people.
But um,
the,
the real idea is like sitting down with
your kids and having a laugh and having
a meal.
I think that that whole process is,
it's very important and
nutrition is very important,
but for me the taste is
very important as well.
I think it's important to eat
things that are delicious.
It fee,
it's like a,
it's a part of like a
pleasurable aspect of life.
And so if I had to choose honestly between
drinking booze and eating delicious
food,
I would go with delicious food.
I think delicious food is more important
because I've experienced the booze and
I understand the lessons,
the lessons of the dropping
of the inhibition and the
good aspects of alcohol,
which are often overlooked by people
who just can't handle alcohol.
Yeah.
You know,
like we were,
we were talking before the
podcast started about not,
this is a fee.
There's certain
level of trust that you have or someone
is willing to get drunk with you.
Like you know that guy's demons,
they're all,
they're all right there.
Five or six Jack and cokes,
you know,
telling a story about
Tiawana and you're like,
Holy Shit,
how did,
Whoa,
what did you tell your mom?
Well,
climbed into my,
you know what I mean?
It's like you get to know a person and
you realize that there's no benefit in
hiding all that shit from PBL love anyway.
There's a benefit and telling them,
right and the sort of camaraderie that
ensues from those drunk and conversations
of,
of complete and total honesty where
the alcohol does a purpose instead of
inhibiting you and making
you make shitty decisions.
The alcohol releases you from this,
this idea that a anything
makes any sense whatsoever.
And you start telling the truth or you
start expressing yourself or you start
looking at things from more
rural relax perspective,
even temporarily or that thought
gets planted in your mind.
And then you just have more of a
sense of friendliness the next day.
Like,
you know,
oftentimes it's,
it's little encounters.
It's steer us and uh,
like I remember this and the
Anthony Robbins quote who,
uh,
believe it or not have,
I've listened to a lot of his books on
tape and read his books and he's got a
lot of interesting ways of looking at
things that I really think are enabling.
But one of the things that he said is
that sometimes if two people are going
along very same path,
like think of yourself as like two boats.
If one boat just turns
one degree to the right,
like over the course of the boats,
motion through life,
just that one decision can lead it so
far away from the original path that it
was on.
And that the,
oftentimes it's a good
time that leads you,
you know,
and it might cost you a day
or two of being hung over.
It might,
but there might be that phone call,
we would call each other on a Wednesday.
Like I had a fucking gray type dude.
That was funny.
I even
have to be,
I'm not even talking about like a crazy
fucking boozy fucking crazy because the
reason why I asked the question is because
whenever I meet people I like and I
respect,
you know,
I,
I'd like to ask them questions because
I believe that's how you learn.
And so I have this problem
because I'll tell you what,
I grew up poor.
I grew up,
uh,
they're poor.
I left home at a very young age
and a lot of what I learned,
I learned initially through books,
you know,
so I'd read books and then I,
that's why I have this sort of a intense
curiosity about the world because I'm
like,
oh fuck,
I like to go there and
see that for myself.
So anyway,
speaking of a general,
so I go to the Ukraine,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm just a regular fucking
dude from butt fuck nowhere.
And I go there and I have this dinner and,
and,
and they bring out these potato pancakes
with sour cream and caviar and vodka
and all this shit.
And I'm,
as you know,
I think it was the first time I
carry and I'm eating it and I'm like,
this is fucking awesome and I'm
loving how we are right off the bat.
Yeah.
First time I ever had it.
Now granted I was a few vodkas in,
but you know,
like jigging,
the voc can eat in the caviar
and it's Russia and it's crazy.
We were up in the middle of
fucking nowhere is not Russia,
the Ukraine.
We're out in the middle of fucking
nowhere and it's some crazy costs act,
shit's going down and it's,
I'm like,
fuck,
this is like living in
a book and it's crazy.
And I,
I literally had one of the best nights
and when it was like living in a,
in a,
in a book from the 18 hundreds so I had
one of the best times of my life then,
you know,
so for,
for the longest time I'm like,
I fucking,
caviar is my favorite fucking food and
this is the greatest thing in the world.
Then I was shooting in Iran,
so I'm going to Iran when the
best carrier comes from now.
And I'm in my hotel room and my
story in my hotel in the ran,
the only hotel foreigners can stay
in they cell caviar in the lobby.
So I'm sitting there
in the lobby and I go,
fuck yeah,
I'm fine.
I love caviar.
That's my favorite shit now man.
So I go and I buy the
caviar right in the store.
It's like the best is,
I don't know,
I bought like $10,000 with the
caviar for 100 bucks or some shit.
So I get it and I go upstairs
but didn't have no booze.
Right.
Cause it's the rent.
So I have like Orange Fanta and some
chips in this caviar and I'm like this is
just fucking salty.
You fucking fishing is
what the police like.
Shit,
what the fuck is it only
tastes good when you're drunk.
I think this is the whole question that
I have is that like when you have a big
fucking Fattal steak with
a good glass of red wine,
how much of it is the fucking red wine
and how much of it is the state when you
have your linguine with clams with a
nice fucking Chris fucking white wine,
how much of it is white wine?
I'm very whatever.
How much is the fucking is the,
is the talk and the,
the thing around,
like you said,
do you have a meal with your family?
How much of that is with the
family and with the thing.
And then so when I was
sitting up there in,
in,
in this fucking Shitty fucking hotel
room in and been Shit Karissa was Phanta
I'm like,
actually I probably just
enjoyed the fucking evening,
you know,
I enjoyed the people and the craziness
and the fucking Bodkin of caviar and the
fact that I hadn't had it before and
everything went fucking ape shit and all
that stuff.
Not h I shouldn't save Shit.
It was a,
it was a very fucking
transformative evening.
And then when I just had the
straight up caviar and like,
man,
I don't know.
Funny what a contrast.
Yeah.
And so when I was asking you the question,
cause we were talking about
food and you were saying like,
you know,
if you have a bad back,
you shouldn't need to pass that.
I'm like,
you know,
Fuck I love,
fuck
no.
What I was saying is that this a
chiropractor that I was talking to,
uh,
over the weekend,
she was explained to me
the influence of a certain,
uh,
wheats and glutens and
how it inflamed tissue.
And that you can get a substantial anti
inflammatory response by just cutting
wheat out of your diet.
Yeah,
I agree with you that there's a pleasure
to eating that I think is like super
important.
It pleasure to eating
and a pleasure to drink.
I mean I like can I smoke weed and
not drink because I would talk to that
problem.
No,
we're not doing that.
For me,
weed is like,
that's the one that really
made a big difference.
Like I think alcohol has played a good
part in a lot of positive aspects of my
life as far as like joyful evening,
having fun with friends and telling
them that you love them and hugging them
and,
and you know,
even whatever,
a romantic altercations,
you know the boys,
no girls bro,
the Shit Brian.
But as far as like what,
what transformed me as a human being now,
marijuana more important.
Yeah.
Merritt marijuana was to
me like there was like a,
almost like a missing piece to my sort
of conceptual puzzle of like how I
interfaced with the,
with nature and with the world.
I was like,
why am I so God Damn Aggro?
Right.
You know,
and then all sudden I find weed.
I was like,
boom.
I know.
Yeah.
For me,
actually booze was my savior because I
was hanging out with a lot of dudes who
are doing some serious,
serious drugs drug and my whole thing was,
I don't want to be 60 years old,
and so I always have this
idyllic sort of retirement,
which I'm trying to get to
sooner rather than later.
Now it's just like just sort
of forgotten like little cove,
you know the little codes
neighbor and my wife,
I'm solar.
I'm sitting there at the school.
I'm going to send you this.
I'm going to send you this,
uh,
this article of this three
and a one and a half.
Dude,
I got a four and a fucking two.
We get to have a party.
I'm going to tell you,
I'm going to send you
are your boys or girls?
Girls.
Okay.
We got a big lesbian super party.
I'm going to send you this article.
It's a fantastic article about a
dude who was diagnosed with lymphoma,
lymphoma,
cancer,
like the worst cancer you can ever.
And,
and he was a Greek dude.
You grew up in America,
but like,
you know,
came here when he was three assumptions.
So he goes back to Greece to this
little island in the middle of nowhere,
and he has to walk up this hill every day.
He goes to talk to his buddies,
drinking the wine,
he's eating the food from the,
from wherever,
and all of a sudden,
like five years.
But he was given like,
you know,
six months to live or whatever,
not even six weeks to live.
And,
and they said,
well,
you know what the fuck happened?
You didn't die.
And he goes,
you know,
I came here and I forgot to die because,
he's sitting there and,
and there's no stress.
And he's walking up the
hill every day and he's,
he's drinking wine with his buddies
and he's eating the food from the,
you know,
the fish from the bay
in the fucking whenever.
And I sit there and I say,
you know,
now I'm looking at this shit.
So my idyllic retirement is basically I'm
stealing this guy who killed cancer by
living this euphoric life of I live on
this little cove and I'm drinking my wine
and I'm sitting out there and I'm
just blissing out on reality now.
That's why I didn't get hooked to heroin.
That's why I didn't get
hooked to fucking crack.
That's why I didn't get hooked all
the shit to my boys got hooked too,
because I always was thought to myself,
if I fucking get hooked to this shit,
I'm going to have to a
die or be fucking quit it.
And if I quit it,
guess what?
I'm never going to be able to sit on that
fucking cove with my glass of fucking
wine sitting out there and being
this blissful old Buddha do,
right.
But when I was a kid,
I thought I was going to die.
So I didn't give a fuck.
I'd do anything cause I'm going to die.
Who the fuck cares?
Why did you think you were going to die?
Because I was going to die.
I mean,
you know,
everybody I grew up with,
when I was a kid died because
we were bad guys doing bad shit.
People die and all that stuff.
How bad were you guys?
Like what did you guys
first thing anybody,
everybody who does like
blow farts on people.
I know Brian.
So it's like,
you know,
look,
you do some gang,
he shit.
You do gang shit.
You doing Canadian gang.
You should.
Yeah,
exactly.
How bad,
how bad you beat,
you know,
look,
people get it.
People get into junk.
It doesn't matter if it's,
by the way,
this is the surprising thing.
Well they get into everything,
but you know,
generally the,
the,
the end result is,
is it,
well now it could be met but
heroin and the thing is is even in,
in Shitty sort of Nice Canada people
end up on junk or they're doing,
they start doing more
and more serious crimes.
And,
and this is one of the
reasons why my my cove was,
was my dream was because you know,
you have guys who are dying of heroin
overdoses are guys are going to prison for
life or worse getting killed.
And,
and you know,
these are 1718,
19 year old kids.
And you're sitting there and saying
that's the biggest tragedy is you never
fucking live here.
Use a teenager.
You think you're fucking live your life.
You haven't lived shit.
You haven't done shit.
You haven't seen shit.
Right.
And one of the reasons why I say I'm
going to go out and I'm going to see shit
and I'm going to do all this shit,
whatever is because I didn't fucking die.
Yeah.
But at a certain point
you sit there and you say,
look,
you,
you know,
and I know how hard life is.
We know fucking what good
things are or can be.
Right.
And,
and can be.
And also we realized there's a
lot of people who didn't make it.
You know,
there's a lot of people
who just for one hour,
one reason or another,
they don't get to where you are.
So what I'm trying to say is you,
you know,
you want to get to more of a,
uh,
of an understanding,
and this is why I go back to it.
Like I don't give a fuck
what people think about me.
I don't give a fuck about,
about shit because when you see it,
you sit there and say,
on this hand,
this motherfucker got shot or this right.
I got it right down and
this guy and got into this.
Now to go back to this,
it's quite long winded,
but if you go back to it,
what do I want to do?
I want to sit in the cove with my family,
your family,
hanging out,
have a drink,
enjoying myself.
I don't know how much food.
And although I'm a fat bastard,
I don't know how much food
is going to play into that,
but I definitely want to be sitting there
when that glass of wine looking out at
that cove and just go
on a fucking made it.
And that's why I don't get,
that's why I don't judge anybody,
because I'll tell you what everyone's
trying to get through the day to get to
their Goddamn cove.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].